no sé si se han dado cuenta que en la
vida hay gente que desde muy pequeños
saben exactamente qué es lo que van a
hacer el típico amigo que se está en
secundaria sabe que estos va a estudiar
medicina y habla y camina como como
doctor en en mi caso es todo lo
contrario la verdad es que la pregunta
de qué vas a hacer cuando seas grande o
vas a hacer cuando seas más grande
todavía me genera nerviosismo y no si no
podría contestarlo entonces mis
decisiones de vida académicas y
profesionales no han obedecido mucho a
eso estudié ingeniería industrial porque
me permitía prácticamente hacer muchas
cosas en el futuro después fui 12 años
consultor trabajando en funciones
industrias países diferentes cuando
entré al tec a trabajar también
trabajaba en proyectos diferentes cada
semana pero pero reflexionando sobre
este tema ha habido un par de constantes
en mi vida que han sido mi guía y que
siempre ha buscado hacer uno es siempre
seguir aprendiendo y la segunda es
buscar tener un impacto positivo y
ayudar a los demás entonces dado dado
eso mi reflexión ha sido que puedo hacer
con lo que es
y con lo que me gusta hacer para cumplir
con estos dos conceptos
en los últimos años me he dedicado al
tema de la educación y en particular el
tema de la educación en negocios
y es de lo que quiero hablar en esta en
esta charla no ahora en las últimas
semanas cuando meto para amigos que les
platicaba que iba a dar un texto que
veían en redes sociales y me decían oye
qué vas a hablar les decía no puedes
leer las empresas y el capitalismo se me
cambiando con cara de ya te equivocaste
compadre por qué no hablas mejor de de
la paz mundial o de salvar a la vaquita
marina o algo que sea verdaderamente
bueno y relevante no para para la gente
que te va a ir a escuchar pero dadas
esas respuestas creo que es todavía más
importante compartir las ideas que voy a
compartir hoy
si ustedes van a allá afuera y preguntan
oigan funciona el capitalismo es bueno
el capitalismo para la sociedad las
empresas son buenas para la sociedad las
empresas pueden ser un modelo de
transformación social y de creación de
valor la mayoría de la gente les va a
decir que no
de hecho hay una encuesta de gallup en
eeuu y no es muy diferente en méxico que
dice que sólo el 18% de las personas
confían en las empresas por debajo de
los sindicatos por debajo de los medios
de comunicación y ahí parece ando con
con los políticos
incluso
escuchamos todos los días en las
noticias manifestaciones en contra el
capitalismo la globalización y las
empresas
hace dos semanas me invitaron a dar una
conferencia al world business council
for sustainable development es una
organización de 200 empresas a las que
van directores generales era una plática
sobre talento y liderazgo para la
sostenibilidad y al final las preguntas
que me empezaron a hacer era porque en
las escuelas de negocios imponíamos el
capitalismo y destruyamos la creatividad
de nuestros alumnos en un evento
organizado por la iniciativa privada y
las propias empresas hace un año estuve
en austin en un evento con john mack que
es el es el fundador de the whole foods
y de un ejemplo que se me quedó grabado
si analizas las series de televisión y
las películas más del 90% de los
asesinatos los cometen hombres de
negocios cuando en la realidad eso es
menos del 2 o 3 por ciento ya como
sociedad hemos encontrado en el hombre
de negocios a nuestro villano favorito
no ahora esta narrativa y este concepto
que tenemos obedece a la realidad o no
si ven en un horizonte de muy largo
plazo que ha pasado con el desarrollo
económico en los últimos 2000 años la
verdad es que del año 0 al 1500 no pasó
mucho incluso después del 1500 hasta
hace como 200 años no habían cambiado
mucho las cosas en cuanto a el producto
interno bruto que generábamos por
persona o per cápita hace 200 años poco
más de 200 años más del 90% de la
población vivía en extrema pobreza el
ingreso per cápita era equivalente al
que tienen países hoy como que tendría
hoy bangladesh o haití si agarras el pib
per cápita de chiapas que es el estado
más pobre en méxico lo divides entre 4
es el nivel de ingreso con el que
vivíamos hace 200 años
y ahora se ha multiplicado ese ingreso
pues casi por más de 20 en muchos países
ahora que pasó lo que sucedió fue el
capitalismo y sus postulados
fundamentales el derecho de propiedad
privada el emprendimiento el libre
mercado la globalización y el respeto a
la ley o el estado de derecho en los
últimos 200 años estas ideas que
empezaron como ideas se fueron haciendo
realidad y transformaron de manera
importante el sistema económico y el
sistema político en la gran mayoría de
los países del mundo no ahora
seguramente me imagino que están
pensando bueno pues esto funciona para
los ricos en promedio si ahorita llegar
a bill gates y centrada y entré a la
sala en promedio seríamos
multimillonarios pero la realidad es que
nuestra realidad no habría cambiado
mucho y la verdad es que es que tampoco
esto este sistema ha beneficiado
principalmente a los pobres también si
preguntas allá afuera que ha pasado con
la pobreza en los últimos 40 años ha
aumentado ha disminuido la gran mayoría
de la gente te diría que ha aumentado
sin embargo alrededor de
en los últimos 40 años yo tengo 39 desde
que nací la pobreza pasó de representar
el 40% de la población a menos del 15
representado por personas que viven con
menos de 1.25 dólares al día y la verdad
es que la tendencia sigue para abajo si
no echamos a perder algunas cosas es muy
probable que en las próximas décadas
como humanidad tendríamos las
herramientas para erradicar la pobreza
ahora sí esta es la realidad porque
seguimos pensando así este se desconecte
es algo por lo que a mí me preocupa y
creo que es hay que hablar del tema
entenderlo conocerlo y platicar lo ahora
dicho todo esto pues el capitalismo está
lejos de ser una un sistema perfecto y
sin duda hay empresas que han destruido
el medio ambiente que han abusado de sus
empleados que son parte del sistema de
corrupción que hay en mexico y en verdad
lo creo y creo que es algo que hay que
combatir y principalmente la gente que
creemos en este sistema económico y que
creemos en las empresas con un motor de
transformación social somos los primeros
que tenemos que señalar a estas personas
que no están cumpliendo con estos
preceptos y en el mundo hay muchos
movimientos que están hablando de cómo
re imaginarnos el capitalismo
hay uno que se llama capitalismo
consciente capitalismo incluyente
capitalismo justo las corporaciones ve
pero todos son alrededor de encontrar
una manera de hacer que el capitalismo
sigue funcionando pero funcione de
manera más incluyente para todos en
particular en el hace cuatro años en el
70 aniversario del tec en la ciudad de
mexico trajimos a war sisodia es el que
escribió este libro junto con john makin
de coaches capitalismo
en donde en esa plática y a través del
libro y una serie de conferencias que
está oyendo hablan de las empresas como
las empresas pero no cualquier empresa
las empresas bien administradas con un
sentido de propósito más amplio que solo
ganar dinero con una visión de generar
valor compartido de stakeholders de
grupos de interés de cuidar no sólo los
accionistas sino de cuidar a los
proveedores a los clientes al medio
ambiente la comunidad a los empleados
son la mejor manera que tenemos yo les
diría casi la única de crear valor para
todos porque no hay otra manera de crear
valor que no sea a través de la empresa
la innovación y la toma y la toma de
riesgos
ahora también me imagino que están
pensando cuántas de estas empresas hay
no y menos en méxico la verdad es que a
través de mi experiencia me ha tocado
conocer a muchas empresas de éstas de
todos tamaños chicas pequeñas grandes y
si las hay ver no las hay suficientes
entonces el reto es cómo formamos a los
líderes futuros ya los líderes actuales
para que creen empresas conscientes
empresas con un sentido de propósito más
amplio o para que transformen a las
actuales en este sentido de esta visión
de la responsabilidad que puede tener
una empresa y del impacto que puede
tener una empresa de transformarla la
sociedad y ese es el sueño ese es el
sueño que yo tengo en lo personal ese es
el sueño que compartimos en la escuela
de negocios del tecnológico de monterrey
y ese es el sueño por el que estamos
trabajando ahora que les pido a ustedes
dos cosas uno que me crea en este que se
lo creen ustedes que verdaderamente las
empresas lejos de ser el enemigo son la
mejor manera que tenemos de crear valor
a la escala que lo requerimos si
queremos sacar de la pobreza al 15 por
ciento que nos falta y el segundo
ustedes todos los días todo el tiempo
interactúan con empresas principalmente
como clientes y como consumidores y la
belleza de este sistema es que nadie los
obliga ustedes tienen la libertad de
elegir con quién interactuar también son
empleados son inversionistas son
fundadores de empresas así que ustedes
también a través de la interacción con
todas estas empresas pueden ayudar a que
más empresas y más empresarios se muevan
a esta visión de responsabilidad social
de un capitalismo consciente de un de un
modelo en donde las empresas sean
verdaderamente un eje de transformación
y de creación de valor más incluyente y
más justo para todos muchas
[Aplausos]